ورغمه حديثي بوشنا عن السيطره على نصف
مساحه مقاطعه دونياسك الا ان المسؤوله
الموالي لروسيا وخلال حديث لوسائل اعلام
روسيه اضاف ان الوضع صعب على طول خط تماس
في مدينه الايمان شمالي دنيا اسكو ان
القوات
الاوكرانيه تشنها جمال معاكسه هناك وفي
مدينه مرينكا نقلت وكاله تتاس الروسيه عن
مسؤولا موال لموسكو ان قواتهم حصلت
المدينه وان قتال عنيفا يدور في شوارعها
الروايه الاوكرانيه المقابله جاءت عبر
هيئه الاركان العامه التي قالت ان قواتها
صدت هجوم الروسيه على مدينه ماريكا كما
قال الجيش الاوكراني وانا روسيا تواصل
محاولاتها للتقدم والسيطره على مدينه
في مقاطعه دنياك وكان الرئيس الاوكراني
قال قبل ايام القصبه الروسيه دمر مدينه
باخ موت والحق اضرار كبيره